[Musique]
bonjour 42-16 merci beaucoup d'être en
direct avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
est ce que ce procès pour vous êtes un
procès qui aura des répercussions sur la
campagne présidentielle vous poser une
question un peu politique parce qu'on
connaît pas évidemment l'issue de ce
procès
bonjour ce n'est pas la vocation du cros
est la vocation du procès c'est de voir
si les infractions qui sont reprochés à
monsieur benalla c'est à dire les
violences aux personnes et usage de faux
passeport diplomatique
si ces infractions sont établis
maintenant évidemment s'agissant d'un
ancien collaborateur du chef de l'état
il est probable qu'il y ait une onde de
choc politique c'est à dire une
exploitation de ce qui sera révélée ou
pas tant dans les débats et puis à
l'issue du délibéré de revenir sur ce
collaborateur qui a seul avis était
licencié par le palais de l'elysée au
lendemain du scandale donc savoir s'il y
aura une onde de choc politique je me
serais vous le dire n'étant pas un
expert dans la matière ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que ce n'est pas ce qui
va préoccuper les juges qui vont siéger
au tribunal correctionnel pour juger
monsieur benalla et ses coprévenus vous
dites que l'elysée a licencié alexandre
au pénal a effectivement au lendemain de
la révélation de cette affaire mais
quand même la faire de ces passeports
diplomatiques qui sont aussi qu'ils font
aussi l'objet de ce procès d'alexandre
reynal à qui s'ouvre aujourd'hui est ce
que l'état pour vous en tant qu'avocat
n'a pas une part de responsabilité en
ayant laissé des passeports valides à
alexandre biennale a alors d'aller
raison bien sûr qu'il ya une
responsabilité du fonctionnement de
l'état a dit si monsieur benalla a usé
de méthodes frauduleuses pour obtenir
ces passeports diplomatiques l'état est
également victime puisque ce sont les
passeports diplomatiques délivrés par
l'état français qui ont été indûment
octroyé à monsieur benalla vous avez un
deuxième sujet sur la responsabilité de
l'état sait qui sera certainement
abordée pendant ce ce procès est de
savoir comment monsieur benalla a réussi
à obtenir les images de vidéo protection
de la place de la contrescarpe
par le biais de la préfecture de police
de paris donc oui il ya des
effectivement vous avez raison des
dysfonctionnements de l'état la part de
responsabilité de monsieur bénin reste à
établir est-ce que c'est lui qui a
fraudé
l'obtention soit des documents
diplomatiques
soit des documents vidéo sur le
tabassage d'aider des manifestants ou si
des hauts fonctionnaires ont de leur
plein gré octroyé à monsieur benalla
lesdits documents alors point de départ
de la faire vous l'évoquiez cette
fameuse vidéo où on le voit alexandre
benalla avec un casque des forces de
l'ordre on l'a par anton pour l
apparente à un policier très clairement
dans ce contexte on peut le dire
aujourd'hui il a outrepassé ses
fonctions sa fonction à ce moment là
sans aucun doute sans aucun doute sinon
il n'y aurait pas de poursuites je crois
même d'ailleurs que nout you benalla on
vient lui même si je me souviens bien
les déclarations qu'il a faites à la
commission d' enquête parlementaire
qu'est ce que le faible de porter ce
casque ça veut dire qu'ils se donnent
l'apparence
d'un policier et par conséquent ils
revendiquent une fonction qui n'est pas
la sienne et que c'est pour ça qu'il
intervient comme un policier donc si
vous voulez l'aïe il ya clairement une
infraction qui est qui est commise parce
que l'opposition par là d'une affaire
d'état quelles interrogations ce procès
justement doit permettre de soulever
si vous voulez la natte héros gay
turquie est une interrogation classique
de savoir quel était le fils de pub ce
collaborateur et et qu'est-ce qu'il
s'octroyait comme prérogatives alors que
toutes ses prérogatives sont encadrer
légalement par l'obtention de soi du
permis de port d'armes soit de
qualification pourrait faire partie des
services de sécurité donc la question
qui a été posée immédiatement c'est
qu'ils aiment beynat là maintenant il
faut pas être plus il anime la le palais
de l'elysée a toujours eu une des
individus comme monsieur benalla dans
l'entourage du chef de l'état et des
individus qui sont rémunérés pour ce
type de travail alexandre venez là à
rédiger un livre où il n'y a pas
vraiment de révélations il a dit je suis
néanmoins un fusible utile au pouvoir
qu'en pensez vous
mais je vous avoue madame que j'ai mal
saisi ce que ça voulait dire parce que
je n'ai pas bien compris en quoi
monsieur benalla serait le fusible de
quoi que ce soit il a commis des fautes
on lui demande aujourd'hui d'en répondre
devant la justice est la moindre des
choses dans l'intervalle en attendant
que l'instruction aboutissent à ce
renvoi devant un tribunal correctionnel
c'était que l'elysée se sépara d'un
collaborateur qui outrepassaient les
prérogatives qui étaient les siennes
merci beaucoup gars m'ont de 16 pour
votre éclairage ce matin sur rtl france
je le rappelle vous êtes avocat
pénaliste